-I want to get
that truck that --
You know,
Biden was at that Ford thing.
-Oh, the electric truck?
-The electric truck.
I've got to get it.
I want to get it.
And I looked into it.
Because, you know,
I'm a truck driver.
-You're super-trucky.
-I am. I've got an F-150.
-Yep.
-Ask me how big my truck is.
-How big is your truck?
-Big enough.
-Nice.
-But I looked into this,
'cause I got my truck
because I wanted to haul
pumpkins around pumpkin season.
-Pumpkin lattes or pumpkins?
-Pumpkin season --
Pumpkins, man.
Pumpkin season comes, what are
you gonna do?
Put a towel down
in the back seat?
-No. You'd look like a fool.
You got to get a truck.
-I strap it into the kids' seat
and make sure the pumpkin --
I don't have room for a pumpkin.
-Ridiculous. Ridiculous.
-You get a Ford F-150,
you can throw like
100 pumpkins in the back.
-1,000 pumpkins.
You get a trailer hitch,
you're set.
-Yeah. Anyways, I love it.
It's bigger than my first
studio apartment, definitely.
It is the most roomiest,
best thing in the world.
I love it so much.
But, anyways,
this new one is the jam,
this new electric one.
They're just announcing it.
So, it's the fastest
acceleration of any F-150 --
zero to 60 in 4 1/2 seconds.
-Ooh! There goes
the pumpkins out the back.
-Yeah. Yeah.
And then, that's how
you make pumpkin latte.
-Exactly.
-Yeah. Forgot to
put the hatch up, yeah.
Tows up to 10,000 pounds.
So I don't even have to have
the pumpkins in my truck.
-No. You have a trailer
and 10,000 pounds a pumpkin,
guess what --
you're set for a week.
-No, this is the thing
that I wanted to talk about
that I looked into.
Listen to this. It's electric.
-Yep.
-It stores enough back-up power
to power a home
for several days.
-What?
-So you plug your house
into this thing.
-What?
-Dude, I would
just live in the truck.
-Yeah.
-It can power a house
for several days.
-Several or seven?
Either way,
that's a lot of power.
-Several.
-Several days.
-But then, here's the jam.
So, they don't have
an engine, right?
Because it's a battery thing.
I don't know how it works.
But all the engine is
underneath, I guess.
-Right.
-So there is no engine
in the front.
-Yeah.
-So they changed
the front to a trunk.
So, they're calling it --
No, I swear.
They're calling it a frunk.
-A frunk?
-Yes!
-So you'd have frunk
in your trunk?
-No, there is no trunk.
-There's no trunk.
There's just a frunk.
-This frunk is -- You can put
whatever you want in --
You can put the trunk
in your frunk.
-Can you put pumpkins
in the frunk?
-Yes!
Oh, this holds -- Because I was
looking into it and I go,
"Well, talk to me
about the frunk,
'cause you can't fake the funk
on the nasty frunk.
It holds 400 pounds of payload.
-Payload.
-Pumpkins.
-Yeah.
-Payload.
Power open and close. Sure.
Power outlets in the frunk.
But then check this thing out.
So, I don't even know
if I understand this.
Because there's no photos of it.
-You're gonna make
a schematic now of the frunk?
-Well, I'm just trying to see
if we can --
-Right.
♪♪
And he kept on writing
for seven days and seven nights.
-Alright, here you go.
-Alright.
Let me see the frunk.
[ Music stops ]
-Well, no, I just did that,
and that looks weird now, so...
♪♪
So, I got to do that there.
Alright, so,
this is kind of the idea.
Alright, look.
Here is the new
Ford F-150, right?
So, this is it.
-Is that "Fisco"?
-This is officially it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, that's the -- I messed up
'cause I got too detailed.
And then I go, "Oh, once I put
the steering wheel,
then I got to put,
you know, the mirror in."
-Because I didn't --
Now that you've drawn that,
it's totally clear.
I had no idea what you meant
by -- I was totally confused.
I was going, "What are you
talking about?"
Wait. Where are my car keys?
I'm confused."
Oh, I see. It's a frunk.
-But check this out.
So, the frunk -- So, also,
check this thing out.
In the frunk itself,
it's water-resistant, okay?
So they --
And they have a drain in there.
-Oh.
-I went on all sort of websites.
-Dude, I've got it.
-Hot tub?
-You put your beer in there.
It's a Frunky Brewster.
That's where the keep your beer.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Only if you're not driving.
Only if you're not driving.
-Yeah, not driving.
You're parked.
-Yeah, or it's
a non-alcoholic beer.
-Right. Like pumpkin beer.
-You can -- I did read,
you can put ice in the frunk.
-Oh.
-So it's a giant cooler.
-That's awesome.
-And as it drains -- But
you know what I'm going to do?
-What?
-Fill it with water
and get a little hot tub.
-That's what I'm saying.
You get like two
sous vides -- right? --
put them on either side.
-Ford -- And they -- Ford knows,
because I do drive
my truck everywhere.
I'm into this thing.
I want to go electric.
Find me.
Yeah, find me.
Is that what I said?
-Yeah, "Find me. Find me, Ford."
-Find me.
That's what I'm talking about.
So, Ford, I'll put up
the bat signal tonight,
and then you put up --
-Frunk signal.
-And you put up your frunk
signal and try to match it
so that our signals
are crossing.
But I want to go electric.
I'm ready for this.
Because you know the
F in F-150 stands for --
-Frunk?
-Fallon.
-Oh, Fallon. Yes.